jason we are here to set the record
straight
the oppenheim group is not a sham you
hire real realtors the women on the show
actually sell houses a ton of houses
why do you think people are so skeptical
yeah i think it's the highest compliment
really because i think this is what's
happening i think they see a show and
they're like okay
there's no way that this is real so i
think that i think if the show
was bad and boring he'd be like okay
it's a real show but it's
but it's boring so i don't that's my
interpretation of it
uh but you know i've encouraged people
obviously to do their research
you can see that we've been kind of
doing this for years let's get to work
i'm jason oppenheim and this is my twin
brother brad together
we built and own the oppenham group
brokerage chair
we are far and away the number one real
estate team in west hollywood
we opened the doors in 2000 end of 2014
and
almost everyone on the cast and this
brokerage has been here pretty much
since 2015 maybe 2016.
what do you make of your kind of your
fellow tv realtors
including the million dollar listing
cast saying we never see these agents at
open houses we don't know who these
girls are i haven't seen it are they bad
realtors
i will say that i've not met them yet
at a listing that i've ever been to or
an open house or anything of that matter
i've never seen any of those people in
real life
except for except for the boys i've
never seen one of those people ever
at any level i will say this i will say
this
the boys are great they're super
successful
and rightfully so the women on the show
are beautiful
um engaging in
in their show and if you notice their
some of their instagram handles really
focus heavily on real estate
[Laughter]
it feels like a dig at you guys yeah i
mean i'm sure it is
it certainly doesn't bother us i mean we
know all of them extremely well so i
guess that part's a little awkward
i consider them all good friends uh
beyond just colleagues so i don't know
where the comments are coming from
you know maybe it can't feel good when
they're being asked about our show when
they when they probably want to be asked
about their show
but you know i think i think the facts
speak for themselves and we do
we're pretty successful and they've all
known me uh
pretty well for quite some years i tell
the team i'm like guys
the more hate like the better the show
like we're definitely doing something
right
with the show becoming bigger and more
people watching it i feel like
people are trying to pick apart little
things about it they're watching it with
a fine-tooth comb
there's even this tick tock that has
gone viral it's incredible
tell me about your client he's a plastic
surgeon
and i have a little bit of a problem
right now i'm trying to hold my client
but he's in europe so i'm gonna try to
call him
the house was for sale i had it listed
with jason
but not christine i've never met her
she's
never been my agent the whole thing
about her not being able to go inside
she's locked out she doesn't have a key
she can't even reach her client
is scripted i see a story there
i i think you know i'm sure she's trying
to get some publicity i mean i know that
woman
i we had the listing on her property at
the time
her i don't know if it was her husband
or her partner or what but there was a
gentleman
that owned a corporation and the
corporation owned that house and i have
a listing i went back and looked at the
listing contract
he signed it and she signed it um
i think she made something of the fact
that she didn't know the agents all the
agents
that is completely normal i mean i have
agents
working on my listings and i would say
most of the time the owner has not met
one or certainly not all of the agents
so to me it was a just a non-issue i
just didn't even understand it is
anything about the show
faked or staged nope the only thing that
i would say
uh would occur occasionally is that
let's say i was going to have a talk
with davina
or you know mary was going to talk to
you know
chris or something like that the
production might say listen guys can we
hold off on this you know until tomorrow
or whatever
so that's not fake to stage by any means
that's simply just kind of
delaying something but they've never
asked
anyone and certainly not me to act a
certain way
or to do anything that's not real so i
know
and the only person who was cast for the
show was krishel she did not work at the
group before the show
that's correct i mean i don't even i had
met and known krishel
previously she was an agent i
put in a recommendation uh for them to
look at it because i wanted her at the
brokerage
so i guess you'd call it casted but
that's the only person that's on this
team that i haven't
it hasn't been in our family for many
many years
but you would have hired her regardless
cameras were rolling or not
he watched i would like to hug on at the
abraham group regardless absolutely
right yeah another person i want to talk
to you about
davina is she really a villain or is she
misunderstood
i'm gonna have to err on the ladder and
misunderstood you didn't get married to
get divorced
you know you know that right
that's why i don't want to do this
anymore i
wanted davina to be at the opperham
group
well before she even joined many years
ago because we had done
transactions together and she was just a
very impressive very professional woman
she is the consummate professional
um i think that she has an honesty about
her that i could that i think could be
misconstrued and i think that
perhaps misinterpreted but i would
certainly say that she's a
a good woman for sure there's nobody at
this brokerage that i wouldn't say that
about
so what's getting lost in translation
what is the audience missing out on
well you know certainly you're not
seeing the day-to-day right and let's be
honest
if there was that it's not like the
drama is going on eight hours a day in
the office i i would
you know dismember myself
so you're getting the you know
production is doing their job
into making a you know a condensed
version of our lives
um and listen i mean christine is a very
you know she can be polarizing and i
think that comes across i think davina
can
have like kind of a rough honesty to her
and i think that comes across but
i certainly think that the type of
vitriol
out there is totally unwarranted i mean
these are good women
you know and good people and good
friends if anyone spent
time with anyone on this team they would
love that that's
that's my belief this isn't about making
points right now can you
stop i'm trying to make i know but you
made your point trust me
can i reiterate and you get off my back
is there anything that's played out on
the show that you've gone
maybe this person shouldn't work for the
oppenheim group
no no i you know
i that would take a lot for me these are
all very close friends
uh many of them are my i consider my
best friends i mean i think that's the
there's a positive and a negative to
working with your best friend
but at the same time i'm way happier you
know working with my best friends in
like a kind of a living room office
environment so
the goods far outweigh the bad screen so
the show
has only helped the brand there's no
hurt coming from
being on reality tv i'm
super excited uh about what's
transpired in terms of the show i think
98
of it has been positive i am so happy
that i did it
safe to say business has gone up with
the
boost of netflix okay absolutely i mean
it really i think you know that was one
of the things i thought about too it did
really help the agents on million dollar
listing
um i did see their careers get bolstered
by the publicity and it absolutely is
helping us too
you know our it helps us market our
properties and and get the publicity for
our properties and we're getting more
calls
so i'm very very happy with the results
well i am anxiously anticipating news on
a season four of selling sunset do we
have
any inkling if it's gonna happen well we
certainly have an inkling just because
i think the show's done quite well um
and we have a great relationship with
netflix i have
no doubt that we will be doing many more
seasons
with netflix in terms of a definitive
answer i think that's gonna come very
soon
from what i hear a season four would
look a little different
brett has struck out on his own has
created his own company
what does that mean that story is is i
would
the press has certainly enjoyed uh the
idea that is
i think that his license is hung uh
independently but we're still working
together he's not
starting in their brokerage and hiring
agents and competing
it's not actually happening uh and we're
still working with it so
we might get into i mean honestly it's
just it's more semantic
it's to the point of being boring uh i
don't think we'll cover it but who knows
so was it that's more of a business back
end decision like
legal stuff yes i mean people want to
think oh the opponent brothers aren't
you know
i don't know i mean we're still best
friends super close still working
together blah blah blah
so it's not as dramatic as uh some of
your your employees have made it out to
sound
christina will be christine if that's
who you're referring to
that's who i'm referring to she's the
one who got that out there
you know you have to love that woman i
feel like you two were a little more
part of
the story in the first season we saw
more interviews with you guys and then
season three i feel like
i was like i was missing where are the
brothers do you want to show more of
your personal lives on the show honestly
i have the best gig
i am cool right where i am i hope at
some point that we delve into me and my
brother being
uh attorneys as well because it hasn't
been addressed in this show either in a
season four a potential season four
would you be more mindful of how often
you're looping mary into deals
in front of the other girls hey i have
something for you
it's just 1.6 but it's a lot of activity
i think it's dope so is jason giving me
another listing
no no because i run my business
appropriately
and i think that's a i think if the
other women
want to pretend that i'm favoring mary
because of our
history i think that that's a disrespect
to
the work that she's doing because quite
honestly she's bringing in a ton of
business
uh to the brokerage the woman is is
killing it and she's bringing in a ton
of business and she deserves
um to be rewarded did you know that she
and romain were legally married
long before they got married on the show
no they didn't let anyone know that but
i mean my understanding now it was a
technical
marriage at a courthouse i mean the
wedding for all of us was the wedding
i don't really care if they signed
documents before or after the wedding i
don't think that's
atypical really um and didn't didn't
shock me or
i saw i read some stuff like that they
staged the wedding on
and that is again i thought that was a
little
i don't mind the criticism but that's a
little disrespectful to someone to say
that your wedding wasn't real
i mean well i i certainly wasn't fake
crying at a wedding you know
with her sister i mean it was i've been
to a lot of weddings that was the most
real wedding i've ever been to
so another change that might happen it
seems like maya
is in miami she's not coming back to
california well you know she's got
clients out here still
i think i'm hoping that she has some
type of presence out here
i certainly have her back and we're
working together i mean literally she
just
called me the missed call from her two
minutes ago
in the middle of this yeah so we're
still working together
we'll see how the long term you know
unfolds in terms of do we do an office
out there
you know do we can we still service our
clients out here uh but right now it's
actually a win-win
because there's a lot of confluence
between new york miami and la
and it's nice i've got people in new
york and it's great great to have maya
in miami
well yeah she wants that o group miami
she wants to do selling south beach so i
mean there's nobody
better for it i mean the woman you know
i trust her she's been at this brokerage
for
since it opened and she's really
experienced uh and i
and again i have a lot of trust and
respect for her so uh she'd be the woman
for it
all right my final question for you yeah
why is the
oh group wine so bad i can't believe we
drink nothing
for a point jesus christ seconds box
that's how you know i'm just desperate
why does everybody hate it so much
oh okay so i'm gonna get i'm gonna get
everyone back because
i'm gonna get i'm gonna buy like six or
seven bottles of good wine like 30 to 50
bucks a piece i'm going to
do a bottle of open home coupon and
we're going to do a blind taste test
and everyone's going to rank them and
we're going to see if it ends up in the
bottom third i will
fully admit then that this wasn't a good
vintage uh for our for our brand
so i'm i won't be defensive but i'm
definitely going to do a blind taster
he won't be defensive but you'll prove
them wrong exactly right